I want to talk about the women's March
and the huge huge anti-trump protestin
DC but all over the world we're talking
about 500,000 people in Washington DC in
the millions nationally
huge fantastic not a single arrest in
Washington DC as of 6 p.m. on Saturday
according to DC police attendance at the
protests drastically overshadowing
attendance at our Orange president's
inauguration absolutely fantastic I went
to the one in Boston on Saturday
absolutely inspiring turnout really good
speakers senator Elizabeth Warren
Senator Ed Markey lots of other elected
officials and activists really good
stuff from Senator Warren specific
pointed strategy opposing specific
initiative how to work it also talking
about science and climate change really
good stuff and then it fell apart so
hard so badly that I left truly
questioning whether progressives will
get it together various activists start
coming up and it's all identity politics
and self-destructive non-strategic
talking points about the patriarchy and
aggressive feminism and speaking as a
blank person type stuff identity
politics failed during the last election
and I said during the post-election
protests in November if you're just
getting the anger and frustration out
now okay
but eventually we've got to get to
productive strategy Trump has been
inaugurated now and I understand feeling
afraid because of your identity but we
know that this laser focus on identity
politics doesn't work the Republicans
put up a laughably unqualified clueless
Orange buffoon and an incredibly
qualified candidate in Hillary Clinton
couldn't defeat him and yes Russia voter
suppression the FBI investigation the
email scandal antipathy towards Obama in
some states it all played a role but it
should have been such a blowout that it
wouldn't even have mattered and identity
politics couldn't even get enough people
out to vote on a single day to defeat
Donald Trump and now identity politics
is going to get people in the trenches
to block legislation and make calls and
send emails and organized boycotts which
is way more energy intensive than just
voting
wrong it's not going to work and Bernie
Sanders had lots of support from the
identity politics types but it was
catalyzed by a focus not on the
immutable characteristics you're born
with but it was a class-based critique
with the understanding that from class
and economics and fighting corruption
and cronyism minority groups are going
to be disproportionately helped the
problem with identity politics based on
race and gender is that you're not
appealing in a similar enough way to
broad enough coalition's the left needs
a real plan here for the next four years
and it's not going to be catalyzed in
any way by ranting about the patriarchy
citing the debunked statistic of 77
cents on the dollar and talking about as
a Muslim woman
dot-dot-dot in many ways a rising tide
lifts all boats as bogus for example tax
cuts for the rich do not help poor
people they give rich people more money
to save rather than invest in the
economy
however dealing with the issues that
affect all people in the lower and
middle classes in other words most
people in our country will most acutely
help the people that are
disproportionately impacted by these
problems this includes racial minorities
ethnic minorities immigrants women LGBT
individuals why was occupied while
opportu by Wall Street so successful in
almost single-handedly inserting the
discussion about income and wealth
inequality into the national dialogue
because they approach the problem from
an economic and corruption perspective
the beneficiaries of the issue will be
those disproportionately affected the
identity groups we've been talking about
what is the goal now of these protests
Trump one we need a plan to block
actions not to talk about the patriarchy
it has to be a message about what is
fair and what is unjust it needs to be a
message about corruption versus
anti-corruption it has to be about who's
lining their own pockets versus who's
actually doing something to help the
average person that's the message that
will unify real broad-based
progressivism rather than getting into
the oppression Olympics or appealing to
specific groups in this way again occupy
wasn't perfect but they did this going
to the
bathroom on police cars all that stuff
around Occupy Wall Street that corporate
media like talking about
but the message transcended identity to
actual equality fairness corruption and
croley crony capitalism and the problems
inherent in the system rather than the
symptoms of right now I hope Pat that my
fellow progressives will join me in
organizing in this way I'm concerned
that the same low percentage of people
will turn out to vote again in 2018 once
the emotion of all this passes we need
to organize to ensure that Republicans
lose control of the Senate and the House
of Representatives in the midterms
there's governors races to work on and
we need to focus on economics corruption
cronyism destructive of vulture
capitalism that is the path forward I
believe yeah and if you even look at the
other side I mean Donald Trump won
because there was this collection right
there was the people who were the more
white working-class voters there were
people who you may even classify as
deplorable 'he's it really takes a
village to win something like this send
me your thoughts about this I am
inspired by the turnout but I am
concerned by some of the specifics and
there were lots of great discussions
that took place but in Boston at least I
was a little worried about where the
focus was if you're just going to call
me not really progressive because of my
criticism you know I don't I don't think
that that is really a good critique
critique the pragmatics of what I am
saying if you want to critique what I'm
saying today's program is made possible
in part by blue apron delivering meals
ready to cook with perfectly portioned
ingredients I love not wasting food and
the great thing about blue apron I just
got a delivery from blue apron a couple
days ago in fact is that every
ingredient comes pre-portioned so that
you don't throw food away some of the
meals available this month include
spaghetti squash and marinara with
mushroom and garlic knots as well as
spicy shrimp and Korean rice cakes with
cabbage which I cooked I think that was
on my delivery a week and a half ago you
can check out this week's menu get your
first three meals for free
with free shipping at blue apron dot-com
/ Pakman that is blue apron dot-com /
Pakman blue apron is the better way to
cook available in 99% of food deserts